[Music]
Magic Johnson opening up about his son
EJ's at sexuality on The Ellen DeGeneres
Show well I think it's all about you not
trying to decide what your daughter or
son should be or what you want them to
become it's all about loving them no
matter who they are what they decide to
do and when my son came out I was so
happy for him and happy for us as
parents and we loved him and EJ is
amazing and so you got to support your
child
MAGIX wife cookie revealed in her 2016
memoir that it took some time for her
and magic to accept EJ you know who he
was and to get on board and I wrote that
chapter that I'm on other young parents
to understand don't wait so long this is
who they are embraced them from the very
beginning but now it's all love for the
family we gotta give EJ the credit
because he's he's really terrific that
camera loves them and now his baby
sister ELISA is a breakout star as well
but mommy manager over here has done a
wonderful job what do you think honey no
I'm so proud of them I mean EJ carved
'sister himself you know he did this he
went out there for it he you know and
he's you know making his own imprint as
he says you know getting out of Daddy's
shadow so we're very proud
[Music]
you